pasamos ahora a nuestra revista de
prensa Como cada mañana con Rosa Pérez
más de Ur Rosa Un saludo para usted
Buenos días Buenos días Ángela vamos a
comenzar hablando de un tema que no es
amable todo lo contrario está sobre la
mesa nuevamente este debate de las
matanzas con armas de fuego en Estados
Unidos después de 18 personas fallecidas
en diversos tiroteos en menos de 48
horas todos en California para entender
la dimensión de estas masacres al
jazzira ha hecho un recuento de los
tiroteos que fueron perpetrados
Precisamente en el año 2022 hablemos de
eso sí exactamente Ángela recordemos
para situar un poco a la audiencia en
contexto que ayer 23 de enero un hombre
mató a siete personas en el norte de
California mediante una armada de fuego
menos de 48 horas después de que otro
hombre de 72 años matará a 11 personas
en una localidad cercana a Los Ángeles
lo que supuso el tiroteo más mortífero
desde que ocurrió el de ubalde en Texas
en mayo de 2022 recor bien a raíz de
estos hechos como bien comentabas al
jazzira intenta repasar el número de
tiroteos masivos que tuvieron lugar en
2022 en Estados Unidos y que encontramos
que no hay consenso respecto a esta
cifra porque hay cinco bases de datos
que registran los tiroteos masivos pero
cada una emplea una definición distinta
entonces en función de la definición que
usa cada registro podemos encontrar que
hubo siete matanzas o 753 veamos las
distintas definiciones
son se dan en función difieren en
función de el número de muertos que se
contabilizan para considerar que un acto
de violencia Armada es efectivamente un
tiroteo masivo también en función de la
localización y de la motivación de los
agresores veamos a continuación la
infografía Ángela que ha realizado al
jazira y nos fijamos por ejemplo en el
violence archive que es uno de una de
las bases de datos más utilizadas por
los medios de comunicación vemos que en
este caso el gran violence archive
considera tiroteo masivo un ataque con
arma de fuego en que cuatro o más
personas mueren y o resultan heridas
incluyendo al atacante un acto de
violencia Armada que tenga el lugar en
un lugar público o privado no importa y
por cualquier motivo ya sea por racismo
ataques de odio robos o violencia de
género según estos criterios en 2022
hubo 647 tiroteos masivos en los que
murieron
673 personas y 2.700 resultaron heridas
Según a la misma base de datos en lo que
llevamos de 2023 entre el 1 de enero y
el 23 de enero de 2023 se han registrado
39 tiroteos masivos en el país y bien
para concluir con este tema lo que
señalan muchas ong o asociaciones que
instan a que haya mayor regulación de
las armas de fuego de la venta y del
porte es que esta disparidad de
criterios y el hecho de que el FBI No
contabilice tampoco los tiroteos masivos
lo que impida es tener transparencia y
una conversación a Clara y aunque todo
el país esté en la misma página para
entender la dimensión del problema y
solo para finalizar Ángela recordemos
que el tiroteo masivo más mortífero en
la historia de Estados Unidos fue el que
tuvo lugar en Las Vegas en octubre de
2017 en el que murieron 60 personas Pues
bien es un completo reporte y no le
parece a usted muy duro que tengamos que
hacer clasificaciones por supuesto
Ángela porque al final se considere uno
tiroteo masivo al final lo que importa
son las vidas no que se pierden Pues con
esta venta y este descontrol de las
armas de fuego que sin lugar a dudas No
es la motivación final de los agresores
pero es algo que facilita no estas
masacres bueno Y finalmente no se hace
nada al respecto vamos a cambiar de tema
Vamos América Latina más a un tema
diplomático hoy comienza la celac
Argentina y hay una cuestión que ha sido
destacada por muchos medios de
comunicación y es el regreso de Lula da
Silva fortalecido y pues que además ha
animado a otros líderes a que vayan
también a la celac efectivamente y
precisamente lo que destaca en muchos a
titulares regionales es el encuentro
entre Luis Ignacio Lula de Silva y el
presidente de Argentina Alberto
Fernández en la digamos anfitriona no de
esta cumbre de Estados latinoamericanos
y del Caribe y en relación a esta Cumbre
el país titula Argentina y Brasil
relanzan la relación con el proyecto de
una moneda común sin perder el regalo ni
el peso y es un artículo de mar
centenera y naiara galarraga que dicen
que esta moneda diferencia del euro por
ejemplo no circularía libremente por
distintos países sino que sería una
moneda para transacciones comerciales y
financieras para depender finalmente
menos del dólar y también señalan las
dos periodistas que para Alberto
Fernández recuperar un Aliado del peso
de Brasil le da mucho oxígeno en este
año electoral también señalan que uno de
los principales proyectos entre
Argentina y Brasil es el gasoducto
Néstor kirchner y que precisamente
Fernández pide financiación parcial a
Brasilia para acabar con este gasoducto
y llevarlo hasta la frontera que separa
ambos países para exportar gas argentino
hacia Brasil y por último este artículo
del país también destaca la complicidad
entre ambos mandatarios que fue pues
expresa ayer en rueda de prensa Bueno
también hay pues la especificidad de la
página 12 no exactamente este medio
también de Argentina dice volvió Brasil
más que una moneda común una relación
económica más fuerte dicen la
integración energética este gasoducto
como decíamos o la recuperación del
comercio bilateral perdido durante la
presidencia de bolsonaro son algunos de
los temas no a seguir en esta
recuperación de relaciones entre ambas
potencia regionales y también tenemos
carta capital que es de Brasil que va
con una cita de Fernando adat el
ministro de hacienda de Brasil le dice
llegó el momento de ser más ambiciosos
en las pretensiones regionales no
también señala que esta moneda que
quieren poner sobre la mesa Brasil y
Argentina podría servir a cualquier
intercambio entre dos países de la
región y que finalmente dice hay que
recuperar el terreno perdido y es que en
los últimos 10 años Brasil habría
perdido un 40% de su espacio de Mercado
en Argentina según el nuevo ministro de
hacienda de Brasil Pues bueno veremos a
lo largo de la jornada Cómo se
desarrolla esta reunión aquí en France
24 lo estaremos reportando y le adelanto
que nuestro segundo invitado del día va
a hablarnos precisamente sobre eso Por
el momento Gracias Rosa y la esperamos
mañana sobre todo los televidentes con
más propuestas para leer de una manera
diferente las noticias Muchas gracias
Ángela